le pass sanitaire est décidément une
mesure controversée alors qu'il suscite
un mouvement de contestation inédite
dans le pays en pleine période estivale
à toulouse c'est au tour des
restaurateurs et cafetiers de pousser un
coup de gueule dans une tribune engagé
il dénonce les conséquences du passage
du ter sur leurs activités il nous faut
dorénavant accueillir nos clients dans
un climat de suspicion déplore-t-il dans
le texte dans lequel il s'inquiète
également pour la santé mentale et
physique de leurs salariés en première
ligne pour faire respecter cette mesure
face aux clients nous sommes d'ailleurs
la rencontre d'yves baduel gérant du bar
l'otan à toulouse qui nous explique
pourquoi il a signé le texte est ce
qu'ils aimeraient voir bouger départ que
depuis le 14 juillet on est en baisse
total le rapport déjà en vacances
du coup on est à peu près à 45 ans 30%
de moins disons les 50 facile -
qu'est-ce que vous préconisez vous du
coup mon autre écologiste l'état il
faudrait que c'est un cri d'alarmé il
faut bien le dire que en fin de compte
il anticipe très rapidement qui nous
laisse au moins la liberté de
l'extérieur terrasses et autres parce
que le fait de faire ça en fin de compte
les gens sont plus à l'aise les gens
reviendront à la consommation parce
qu'en ce moment ça boude est-ce que vous
avez le pass and it erp vous pas le pas
sur les terres
parce que j'ai peur chez
moi j'aimerais bien que le président
avait relevé ce voilà je pars ciani
c'est parce qu'il ya des gens
franchement vit dans le stress on vivre
mal on n'a même pas le droit prend un
cap et que les gens devraient pouvoir
s'auto discipliner quand ils viennent
s'asseoir en terrasse ou quand il rentre
dans un restaurant devrait être
conscient qu'il est nécessaire d'avoir
le pass sans forcément engager la
responsabilité du restaurateur ou des
chefs d'établissement
déjà fragilisée par plus de 16 mois de
restrictions et 8 de fermeture avec pour
conséquence une baisse un chiffre
d'affaires en chute libre ces
restaurateurs et cafetiers demande donc
au gouvernement plus de compréhension et
de cohérence sur une mesure qui ne fait
que crispé salariés et clients et qui
accentue de fait une baisse de leur
activité